Accuracy is an obvious issue with our computer-based solution.
To check what the computer does, the easiest way to learn
what goes wrong with the computer simulation is to use a toy example,
which we can compute by hand as well.
This toy example will be a circular orbit.
A space craft moving around earth for instance with the earth at the center of this orbit.
Let's call the radius of that orbit r and let's call the orbital period
the time its takes for one orbit capital T.
The velocity vector of that spacecraft will be tangential to that orbit
and the speed that is the length of that velocity vector.
The speed will be constant and we can't easily compute the speed.
It takes the spacecraft amount of time, capital T, to go around that circumference
and the time capital T, the distance traveled by the space craft is 2 πr circumference of that orbit.
The acceleration vector of these points perpendicular
to that orbit to the center of the earth.
The acceleration does not change the speed, the length of the velocity vector that is,
it simply changes the direction of that vector.
We can compute the length of that acceleration vector in a similar fashion. This goes as follows.
We start with the velocity vector that takes us up
and then we move and then the velocity vector changes to the left.
At this point, it points to the left and eventually it goes round to full circle.
After one orbital period, it's going to be that blue vector again with phase shift of 90°.
So we can't say that the velocity vector executes the same circular motion
as does the position vector that we have a phase shift of 90° between them.
Nonetheless, we can still apply the same equation.
It takes us one orbital period to make one full revolution and that has a length of 2 π*r.
All of these vectors have the length of 2 πr/T.
So the circumference would be 2π times this radius 2 πr/T, which boils down to (2π)² r/T².
So given the radius and the orbital period of this circular motion,
we can determine what the speed is and what the acceleration is.